en 2002 les vestiges du château médiéval
devoldre eux n'en était invisible
la faute à la nature qui avait repris
ses droits et occuper la place
mais au fil des étés et des campagnes de
fouilles l'édifice du xiiie siècle
plusieurs fois rhmani s'est dévoilé
l'objectif est de déjà de de découvrir
ce qui reste du site pour le présenter
au public sans intention par exemple de
reconstruire des bâtiments en complet
ils sont trop ruiner c'est avant tout
une recherche sur les ruines du château
pour le pour le faire comprendre aux
visiteurs un chantier conséquent et
mobilise une trentaine de bénévoles qui
viennent manier pelles pioches truelle
et brouettes quinze jours par an aux
fidèles présents depuis le début ou
presque
s'ajoutent toujours quelques petits
nouveaux chais au lycée à salins les
bains et il ya dix points mon amoureux
que je connais d'ici et du coup il m'a
on ici l'année dernière pour le voir du
coup j'ai rencontré un peu les gens et
tout mais j'ai trouvé l'ambiance est
super cool du coup je suis revenue cette
année
moi c'est pas je cherchais pas un
chantier ou quelque chose comme ça
c'était pour aventures d'un été où d'une
vie amélie a eu ici une révélation
j'ai commencé en fait le chantier de
veules grenon à 16 ans en tant que
jeunes du chantier de jeunes et j'ai
découvert une passion et un métier donc
j'ai poursuivi des études en archéologie
et maintenant je suis en doctorat à
l'université de besançon le plus bel
objet que nous ayons pour l'instant
remonter c'est une cuillère au bois qui
est complète avec son manche qui est
complet on avait autrefois des cuillères
avec des manches très court pour pour
l'orangé dans sa besace quand on se
promène des objets qui vont être triés
étudier dans leurs moindres détails et
répertoriés à l'issue de cette 18e
campagne de fouilles qui se termine
vendredi